E aí
e em 1926 o Brasil tinha um novo
presidente Washington Luís e ele se
destacou na campanha presidencial com
seguinte slogan governar é Abrir
estradas desde então o Brasil entrou
numa corrida por abertura de novas
estradas e rodovias A exemplo de outros
países mais desenvolvidos como Estados
Unidos e Alemanha essa estratégia deu
tão certo que atualmente o Brasil tem a
quarta maior malha rodoviária do planeta
são cerca de 1 milhão e 700 mil km de
estradas e rodovias uma extenção tão
grande que a gente poderia ir à lua por
até cinco vezes apesar dos inegáveis
benefícios socioeconômicos gerados pelas
rodovias também são inegáveis os
impactos ambientais causados por elas a
gente pode citar perda de vegetação
natural fragmentação mudanças micro
climáticas hidrológicas e o
o momento de animais silvestres existe
uma perda muito grande de animais
silvestres no Brasil porque ao mesmo
tempo que a gente tem uma marca de
muitas rodovias Nós também temos uma
outra marca muito importante o Brasil o
país número um em diversidade biológica
do planeta 14 de todas as espécies
viventes na terra ocorrem no Brasil Isso
significa que nós temos conflitos com
sal nas nossas rodovias todos os dias
todas as horas em muitos lugares minhas
pesquisas recentes demonstram que
somente nas rodovias do Estado de São
Paulo morrem atropelados todos os anos
39.600 indivíduos e mamíferos silvestres
de médio e grande porte são seis mil
cachorros-do-mato 5.000 capivaras e
5.000 tatus os números se tornam mais
assustadores e mais impactantes quando a
gente pensa em espécies que já são
o resultado de extinção 150 lobos-guarás
150 tamanduás Bandeiras uma centena de
jaguatirica e 50 onças pardas repitam
Esses são Dados exclusivos para o estado
de São Paulo imagine vocês Qual é o
tamanho desse Impacto massivo e crônico
na fauna brasileira em todas as rodovias
do Brasil do ponto de vista da
conservação das espécies as rodovias são
como o ralo o dreno da nossa rica
biodiversidade e nós estamos perdendo
até mesmo que a gente ainda nem conhece
esse animal aqui foi atropelado em uma
das rodovias do Parque Nacional da
Chapada dos Veadeiros Paraíso o nosso
país ela se chama jaritataca e é uma das
espécies bem desconhecidas pela nossa
população essa foto
é registrada porque enfim foi um dos
atropelamentos que mais me marcou quando
eu peguei o animal na minha mão o corpo
dele ainda estava quente em menos de um
segundo a vida do bicho se foi bem como
todas as atividades bem como todas as
funções ecológicas que ele desempenhava
na natureza virou carcaça desapercebido
na Rodovia mas não pensem vocês que o
atropelamento é um problema somente do
ponto de vista biológico atropelar
animais em rodovias também tem outros
custos custo para a segurança humana e
custos econômicos quando existe a
colisão com animal numa Rodovia existem
dois envolvidos atropelado bicho e
atropelador gente eu você nossos amigos
familiares enfim humanos atropelar
animais de grande porte em rodovias gera
acidentes gravíssimos
as plantas capivaras e veados por
exemplo ainda no Estado de São Paulo
entre 2003 e 2013 foram registrados um
pouco mais de 28 mil acidentes
rodoviários envolvendo animais em
rodovias todos os anos 600 pessoas ficam
feridas e 20 pessoas morrem atender
todas essas colisões já era um custo
econômico para o estado de São Paulo
anual na cifra de 56 milhões de reais
Olha eu peço desculpas porque até agora
eu só dei notícias desanimadoras para
vocês não é mesmo a gente já entendeu
que os bichos são atropelados as pessoas
sofrem acidentes graves enfim existe um
alto custo econômico para o estado de
São Paulo que enfim poderia ser
repassada a outras prioridades da nossa
sociedade o primeiro resumo dessa minha
apresentação é que nós precisa
a dança O Brasil precisa urgentemente
mudar a forma como planeja constrói e
opera as nossas rodovias a segunda parte
dessa apresentação é mais palatável
Fiquem tranquilos afinal de contas
sempre existe a luz no fim do túnel não
é mesmo e no nosso caso o próprio túnel
pode ser uma das nossas soluções uma das
estratégias mais comumente usadas em
diversos países do mundo que tem
demonstrado alta eficiência na redução
dos atropelamentos é a adoção de
estruturas físicas que permite a
travessia segura dos animais nas
rodovias eu tô falando dessas famosas
passagens de fauna que podem ser de
diferentes tipos passagens inferiores de
fauna como túneis passagens superiores
de fauna como viadutos vegetadas e até
estruturas muito específicas quando a
gente fala de animais que são ar
e principalmente as passagens que
inferiores de fauna elas são associadas
a um cercamento específico de fauna você
deve estar pensando ah legal uma
passagem de fauna Mas como que os bichos
vão saber que eles têm que passar
exatamente ali e é exatamente aí que a
cerca entra a função de um tratamento de
fauna se são duas funções a primeira
delas é barrar a entrada do animal na
rodovia e a segunda função é
encaminhá-la até uma passagem segura de
fauna juntas essas medidas podem reduzir
em até 86 por cento o atropelamento de
animais de médio e grande porte Nossa
mas qual a ciência Qual a dificuldade de
se fazer uma cerca para bicho não é
mesmo e aí Imaginem vocês que esse é um
dos maiores desafios da minha área como
especialista em rodovias basta dizer que
os veados pulam as
e o status ca vão os cortes escalam e as
capivaras arrombam acerca como então
pensar num design eficiente para fauna
brasileira nada todas essas condições
Essas são observações evidências de
campo de um programa de monitoramento
dessas passagens de fauna Esses são
Dados preciosos que nos revelam qual
tipo de estrutura é mais adequada para
diferentes espécies e como os animais
têm se comportado nelas mas agora a
gente vai falar de um grupo de fauna bem
específico que são os animais
arborícolas os macacos marsupiais e
roedores que são arborícolas um animal
arborícola é um animal que se desloca
essencialmente pela Copa das Árvores
Nesse caso a palavra de ordem para esses
animais é reconectar reconectar o dossel
Florestal cortado por rodovias e eu fico
muito
e compartilhar com vocês o nosso novo
projeto na Amazônia onde a gente vai
instalar e monitorar 20 dessas passagens
de fauna o que a gente quer saber como
essas estruturas auxiliam na redução de
atropelamento desses animais que também
são espécies ameaçadas Amazônia e como
essas estruturas permitem que os animais
através em as rodovias insegurança
e afinal de contas o ir-e-vir é um
direito irrevogável de todos não é mesmo
bom Se tem uma coisa que nós brasileiros
deveríamos nos orgulhar em relação ao
nosso país é sobre a nossa
biodiversidade não existe riqueza maior
nesse país do que a nossa biodiversidade
e nós todos nós devemos lutar com unhas
e dentes pela Conservação da nossa
biodiversidade o propósito da minha
carreira como bióloga como pesquisador a
cientista e na consultoria ambiental é
proteger a fauna brasileira e apoiar o
meu país em direção a termos
Empreendimentos de transportes mais
sustentáveis
a rodovia sustentáveis significa
engenharia limpa rodovias mais
sustentáveis significa inovação
tecnológica significa ciência eficiência
mas sobretudo significa mais respeito
pela vida animal e humana muito obrigada
e seguimos com tudo isso
[Aplausos]